across the state of Georgia
non-essential businesses have remained
closed for a pandemic that's already
claimed close to 900 lives there are
some signs the outbreak is flattening
but with only a few days of data health
experts are warning it may be too soon
federal guidelines recommend a 14-day
sustained reduction in kovat 19 cases
something Georgia hasn't shown but the
Republican governor is pushing for a
partial reopening given the favorable
data enhanced testing and approval of
our health care professionals we will
allow gyms fitness centers bowling
alleys body art studios barbers
cosmetologist Hair Designers nail care
artist s decisions their respective
schools and massage therapists to reopen
their doors this Friday April the 24th
business owners have been losing income
for weeks that many are confused by
conflicting information and health risks
despite being told to engage in minimum
basic operations the TIF Park Community
Market is not open and that's where I
make most of my money and they have to
stay closed and they should stay closed
because if you lose anybody's life over
money that's wrong in other southern
states small but vocal protests of
growing as unemployment lines get longer
these people gathered outside the
Capitol building in Alabama to make
their voices heard but stay at home
orders remain in place across the
southern states here in Miami Beach's
and businesses remain closed and that's
not likely to change for weeks to come
governor Kemp of Georgia is a close ally
of President Trump's as is this state's
governor Ron de Santos both have been
praised for their reaction to the corona
virus and even as president Trump
encourages protesters he thinks Georgia
is acting too soon the presidents
praised governor Kemp is a very capable
man now he's publicly disagreeing with
his plans they can wait a little bit
longer just a little bit not that much
because safety has to predominate we
have to have that so I told the governor
very simply that I disagree with this
decision
but he has to do what he thinks is right
despite the hardships faced by business
owners in Georgia and other states many
remain cautious about exposing
themselves and others to the coronavirus
many will ignore the governor's advice
others may feel forced to take risks as
the economy continues to falter and a
Galica al-jazeera